if you saw renewed America and by
implication A Renewed West what would
that renewal look like I want us talking
more and acting more on ordering a
country a nation a society grounded in
the value of each individual who is a
member of a family who is a family that
is embedded in a nation with commitments
to that nation and yes I think a Revival
of a belief that we are one nation under
God that doesn't mean a single religion
or a single you know religious Orthodoxy
pushed from on high in fact I think it
shouldn't be so but broadly individual
family Nation God as an affirmative
alternative to race gender sexuality and
climate